I'd like to start with the permission of
my British friends
to just say a few words about the
wildfires in Canada and the quality of
the air here in the East Coast
um this blanket of the communities in
the east coast and uh
and the smoke this past few days
I just put out a more detailed statement
so for the press and for people to see
but I spoke yesterday with prime
minister Trudeau
and I've decided to dictated a National
interagency Fire Center
response to Canada's request for
additional firefighters and the fire
suppression assets such as air tankers
we already have 600 American
firefighters on the ground have been
there for a while in Canada including
Hot Shots and the smoke jumper Crews and
it's very important that affected
communities listen to the guidance of
their state and local officials from
this point forward
keep up to date on the air quality in
real time go to the app that we provide
it's called airnow.gov
and check on one another and by the way
what you'll get is something that looks
like this with a with a calibrated piece
that says when the air is clean and when
the air is dangerous and hazardous and
it dictates what uh well to tell you the
air quality in your the neighborhood